These 4 letters of DNA represent the alphabet of your genetic
code, C, T, A, and G. But every time we use these
4 letters in our DNA, they really represent a specific chemical
structure coded here in the nitrogenous base. Put together
in sequence, many deoxynucleotides. These individual nitrogenous
bases are part of deoxynucleotides that build
up what we call deoxyribonucleic acid. Now,
that name can seem complicated, but it's
really intended just to describe the chemistry
of the molecule. You can see the chemistry actually here. I've written out The
organic chemistry structure of this same sequence
of deoxynucleotides, where you can see each
position there's an atom; nitrogen, oxygen, phosphorous. These are elements
in the periodic table. This is chemistry that makes up our biology of who we
are. The name deoxyribonucleic acid is simply a useful term to describe this
chemistry. Take this individual nucleotide here,
that has a nitrogenous base adenine attached.
Now there are four parts to the title deoxyribonucleic acid. First there's the
deoxy part. Next, there's the ribo- part, then there's the nucleic- part,
and then there's the acid part.
Each of these four parts of deoxyribonucleic
acid describe a specific part of this chemistry.
For example, this part of the molecule
here, called a phosphate group, can actually be
acidic under certain conditions. This part of
the molecule here is called a ribose sugar.
I don't know if you know this or not, but sugars are also molecules. This part
of the sugar right here, is actually missing an oxygen atom. An then I tried
in the space structure we've already mentioned, contains
nitrogen. What I want you to tell me
is which number, from DNA or Deoxyribonucleic Acid
is shown here. Describes which part of the
chemistry of the deoxynucleotide. Now, this could be
a little tricky if you don't have a
chemistry background, but I've tried to lay it out in such a way
that makes it pretty straightforward for you to identify. So if you have
trouble, just go ahead and take a guess, and see if you can
get it right. Put a number into each text box that you see here.